hi there i'm matt vandehart pioneer
field agronomist from central iowa
providing a late season corn update
now i know each year we tell you to go
assess stock quality and grain quality
to set your harvest plans
this year i want to make sure you are
assessing late season plant health and
tar spot we didn't have the right
conditions for tar spot this year across
the midwest or even across iowa we
didn't have a lot of cool and wet
conditions at least in southern iowa
certain parts of iowa have seen some tar
spot really get aggressive here through
august and september
i'm in a field here of a susceptible
competitive hybrid that obviously had a
lot of tar spot in it you know got into
even the upper leaves or just completely
covered in tar spots so septal hybrids
can get affected by
tar spots very aggressively very quickly
but this set in this field late enough
you know we're close to being able to
harvest this field so it may not have
had a yield impact at all but we need to
take note of these fields we need to
take note if you do have some tar spot
out there or some bad late season plant
health it may affect stock quality but
also the next time you have a hybrid
there make sure it has a good tar spot
rating working on ratings that pioneer
we have some preliminary scores and some
that are work in progress but if you
need a hybrid that's good got a good tar
spot tolerance we're gonna give you the
best in our lineup and so be asking
those questions be planning that out the
next time you have corn there take note
of those fields i know some of you may
have some drought stress and it's not
tar spot out there but at least check
those fields ahead of harvest tar spot's
something we need to manage holistically
we need to manage with fungicide time
properly but a lot of that fungicide
residual comes off late in the season
when this aggressive disease comes up
and attacks a lot of susceptible hybrids
so just take note of this disease and
take note of any stock quality issues
ahead of harvest if you've got any
questions on tar spot our tar spot
tolerance ratings from pioneer or even
just questions about laces in plant
health let us know pioneer and have a
happy harvest
that concludes this pioneer agronomy
video podcast visit our page on
pioneer.com and follow us on twitter and
facebook for more agronomy insights